ooh original pipe tobacco this will be
delicious and uh cheesies oh yeah
man that's a Cheesy very good I think
Canada is going to win this round
although I don't know what this
is oh oh that's got a kick to it I'm
going to go I'm going to go with these
probably because they're not uh
Radioactive all right we got Fig Newtons
yeah is that what those are rolls fig
rolls you call them here mhm
yep Wow Cherry Blossom or someone's most
recent dump okay
okay oh that's gross cuz there's like a
a liquidy kind of oozing fake Cherry um
treat coming out of there no thanks UK
wins again God I feel really feel like
I'm betraying my country here